How do we solve this problem? Well, there's two objects we really care about--the two masses.
The pulley we're largely ignoring--the only purpose of the pulley
is to redirect where this rope is going.
Well, two objects means we have to do two diagrams. Let's think of M₁ first.
Well, of course, there's weight going downwards. Every object has its M₁g.
But then the rope is also providing a force and that force is called tension.
Now remember we're dealing with the case where M₂ >> M₁.
So I want to know what's the relationship between this weight
force going downwards and this tension force.
Are these M₁g = FT? Is the M₁g > FT? Or is the M₁g < FT?
So what do you think is the correct answer.